my name is Manuel Menendez I want to
take you out and we're going to try to
catch it in the free dive spearfishing
once you leave the surface it's just so
quiet and we dive and it's just you and
the ocean it's it's pretty wild you know
we're not Aborigines I'm gonna eat
dinner whether or not we catch but
there's something really special on a
primal level about you know me and the
guys forming a hunting party we're gonna
go out and we are gonna get in the water
we're gonna find the target and we're
gonna put them in the core
you know the perversion of what we get
in the cooler you know always wanting to
get something bigger than the last one
of whatever you got these are mangrove
snapper people also call it a gray
snapper you know how to respect for your
prey if I go and I hunt down whatever so
even a lowly Lobster you know I took its
life so I owe it to that Lobster to make
it delicious to use as much of it as we
can and to not let anybody waste it
otherwise we leave it swimming or
crawling until next week nothing tastes
as great as the ones you see yourself
you